m
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich habe auch heute wieder ein
richtig leckeres rezept für euch und
zwar habe ich diese leckeren giotto
haselhorst tabletts gebacken
das ist ein mürbeteig mit einer nuss
füllung und toto kugeln und ich habe
dieses rezept und neun weitere für euch
kreiert und zwar gibt es eins von zehn
rezepten in diesem job aktionspackungen
gibt es für kurze zeit im handel und am
ende des videos gibt übrigens noch ein
richtig tolles gewinnspiel
da kommen wir noch mal später darauf zu
sprechen aber jetzt packen wir erst
einmal die tabletts ich bereite zuerst
denkt so und dafür brauche ich an
zutaten 100 gramm zucker 200 gramm
butter 300 gramm mehl und ein eigelb die
kann man sich ganz gut merken denn das
ist ein 12 3-lauf teig so jetzt gebe ich
einfach alle zutaten zusammen in eine
schüssel und zwar könnt ihr das jetzt
entweder mit einem handrührgerät machen
mit einer küchenmaschine oder einfach
mit den händen verkneten macht das jetzt
kurz in der küchenmaschine um das alle
zutaten gut durchrühren
so den teig verknetet jetzt noch ganz
kurz mit den händen und zwar freue mich
einfach eine kugel draus zusammendrücken
ich habe da jetzt kalte butter benutzt
aber trotzdem muss ich den teig jetzt
für 30 minuten im kühlschrank kühl und
dann geht's weiter
der teig schild noch im kühlschrank
nicht bereitet zumal die füllung vor und
für die füllung brauche ich 300 gramm
haselnüsse 270 gramm zucker 40 gramm
honig 100 gramm schlagsahne zwei
esslöffel milch etwas vanille extrakt
und vier stangen giotto und zuerst nehme
ich jetzt haselnüsse und male sein
ihr könnt natürlich auch fertig gemahlen
nehmen aber so ist es aroma einfach
automatischer schmeckt
die haselnüsse fühle ich jetzt in einer
pfanne und tröstete sie da ohne fett
dann verstärkt sich der haselnuss
geschmack nämlich
die haselnüsse lasst ihr ein bisschen
abkühlen und kann in der zwischenzeit
aber die restlichen zutaten verrühren
also eier und zucker erstmal kurz
berühren damit sich den gut erfüllen
lässt gleich
dann gebe ich sahne und wenn ich mir
dazu und den honig
jetzt kommt auch manila extrakt mit rein
katzen halben teelöffel und bevor ich
jetzt die hasel ist mit dazu gebe mache
jetzt erstmal den teig den bereit ich
kurz vor und holen kurz aus dem
kühlschrank
der teig ist jetzt gut abgekühlt und
dann rolle ich jetzt auf einer silikon
matte aus da brauche ich nämlich nicht
so viel mehl und als hilfe habe ich hier
so zwei hölzer die haben so ein abstand
von 3 mm weil ich möchte 3 mm dick
ausrollen und am besten legt ihr da noch
eine zweite seco matte drauf dann klebt
nicht so sehr
jetzt müsste einfach mal schauen was für
tablett formen ihr habt als ich habe
jetzt hier runde trips aber zum beispiel
auch als herzchen und da brauche ich
jetzt zwölf stück davon
und wer jetzt aber nur vier habt dann
backt sie eben nacheinander ich nehme es
die runden und stellte jetzt den teig
etwas größer als die form aus und wenn
ihr kein ausschuss habe nimmt den glas-
und schälchen teller und könnte es dann
ebenso formen
die förmchen bespricht mit etwas back
trends trades das einfach kurz einfetten
und jetzt könnt ihr den teig einfach
drüber legen und schön in die form
reindrücken
und diese überstehenden änderte nehme
ich jetzt einfach mit einer palette weg
oder mit einem messer
jetzt stehe ich noch ein paar löcher in
den teig damit der teig schön flach
bleibt und den können wir jetzt
natürlich auch blind backen das heißt
ich könnte jetzt ein backpapier
dazwischen lägen zum beispiel
hülsenfrüchte darüber legen getrocknete
beeren oder nicht wehren erbsen meinen
natürlich oder bohnen und ist dann
sofort backen
ich pack das jetzt allerdings einfach
ohne vor als ich praxis nicht blind vor
sondern ganz normal vor
und wenn der teig dann ein bisschen auf
kann immer noch ein bisschen runter
drücken jetzt nämlich einfacher wir wenn
ich jetzt hier in jedes kleine förmchen
backpapier einfüllen müsste
und die backe ich jetzt wie gesagt bei
190 grad ober unterhitze für fünf
minuten vor und in der zeit kann ich
dann schon mal die haselnüsse in die
füllung mit einrühren
ja
so die tat letztlich vorgebacken und
jetzt kann ich mit einem esslöffel die
tabletts fülle ich verteilt jetzt erst
mal und dann streiche ich es glatt
die tat letzten social und super lecker
also eine richtig leckere
geschmacksexplosion aber so richtig toll
wenn es erst wenn jetzt noch drei giotto
kugel damit hinein gibt zum einen sieht
es natürlich viel hübscher aus also
richtig dekorativ und zum andern hat da
einfach nochmals einen crash mit dabei
deswegen jetzt überall noch drei stück
reinstecken
und so werden sie jetzt im ofen noch mal
in 15 minuten fertig gebacken
nach dem backen dass ich sie abkühlen
und wenn sie dann ganz kalt sind zeige
ich sie euch
die tat letzte nichts gebacken und auch
abgekühlt und die lassen sich ganz
einfach aus der form herausnehmen und
zwar habe ich ja diese tablett förmchen
mit dem hebel boden
also kann ich dir einfach herausheben
und unten den boden entfernen
zusätzlich setzt auf einen teller und
ihr seht wahrscheinlich auch die fehlt
nämlich ein tablett und so habe ich das
jetzt gerade probieren müssen denn ich
muss solche die konsistenz richtig
perfekt beschreiben und zwar haben wir
es in der tat letzt einen leckeren mit
boden also richtig möglichst er
und dann haben wir hier oben drauf diese
füllung die ist cremig aber hat auch so
ein bisschen bis ein bisschen krank und
sie schmeckt auch etwas nach karamell
denn der honig und der zucker in dieser
füllung die karamellisieren im ofen dann
und die lottokugeln die bringen dann hat
noch mal so ein bisschen bis mit rein
und die creme da drin als das passt
wirklich alles perfekt zueinander und
für mich sind es wirklich im moment so
meinen lieblings tablet richtig gut
jetzt haben wir zum gewinnspiel ich habe
zehn rezepte für euch mit schotter
kreiert und jetzt seid ihr an der reihe
und zwar habt ihr jetzt die chance eine
von diesen zehn kitchenaid
küchenmaschinen oder 1 von 500 tobak
paketen zu gewinnen und alles was ihr
dafür tun muss ist ein rezept mit giotto
zu kreieren und dieses rezept mit bild
auf dieser unten eingeblendeten adresse
hochzuladen
einsendeschluss ist der 30 sechster und
die otto schily und ich wir wählen dann
die besten rezepte aus und jetzt wünsche
ich ganz viel spaß ganz viel kreativität
beim entwickeln der rezepte und vor
allem viel spaß beim nachhaken
mein rezept gibt es wie immer auf salehs
- dot de oder in diesem motto
aktionspackungen reise immer eins von
zehn rezepte mit dabei also ganz viel
spaß und wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder bis bald